you
probably the low point of any Sinbad
movie is Sinbad himself he's not
especially interesting hero it's more
the creepy creatures I comes across in
the fantastical elements so when I saw
Sinbad legend of the seven seas I was
definitely keeping that in mind and in
many respects this Sinbad is pretty much
the same
he's good-looking a swashbuckler has
sort of a brad pitt personality which
figures cuz he's played by Brad Pitt and
they sadly really cop out with some
lines like pretty cool huh that's
exactly like women shouldn't drive uh
yeah but as the film continued I found
that but less it's sort of tailored to
uh yeah that the more fun and creative
'god when he wanted to treat itself like
a real action-adventure it felt like a
real action-adventure maybe even up
there with some of the original film
series the story Sinbad is a thief who
comes across an old friend who's a
prince he has this magic book that I'll
be very honest I have no idea what it
does is just sort of an important book
that must be kept safe in order for all
the kingdoms to survive but eres the
goddess of things up decides you
want to do exactly that and steals the
book for herself
everyone thinks Sinbad did it but his
best friend the prince thinks he didn't
so he offers up his life in exchange for
Sinbad to go and get the book back if he
doesn't then the prince is dead along
the way he's joined by a stowaway played
by Catherine zeta-jones was going to
marry the prince
which of course makes her the
stereotypical prince ambassador oh so
she actually has a title of
responsibility and does okay I'm an
uncle with that she of course has to
prove to Sinbad that she can handle
herself and maybe even Sinbad the film
definitely sort of moves like a Sinbad
adventure in that it's just sort of an
action-packed road trip they sail the
seven seas come across a bunch of weird
creatures and fight them off in order to
get to their goal and as far as those
action scenes go they're not bad they're
actually a lot of fun to watch and very
creative the characters at times to come
to sort of the typical cliches like the
couple yelling at each other when of
course you know they're gonna get
together those horrible modern-day
catchphrases which like I said aren't
often but when they do they stick out
like
sore thumb and once in a while a CG
monster that looks just a little too
fake but let's get down to what the best
element of the movie is the villain oh
not that Arras is a particularly complex
character or really even that
interesting but by God look at the
animation on her the way she moves the
way she teleports the way she shifts
shapes I don't know who the animation
team was that worked on her but give
them all friggin Oscars this stuff looks
wonderful
she moves as if she can be anything or
anywhere her pets are literally the
constellations that come to life the
world she lives in is a mystical marvel
it's just no every single time she's on
screen I just loved it every single
second like look at this here she's
supposed to turn into Sinbad and steal
the book now obviously you could have
her just shape-shift or walk behind a
wall and she comes out as Sinbad or
something but look at this she makes a
puppet version of Sinbad and then slips
into his skin who would even think of
that it's just that kind of creativity
is spectacular
an actress Michelle Pfeiffer who does
the voice obviously loves eating out the
role but like I said the animation on
her alone is worth it so on the whole
Sinbad is fun it does leave room for
some character development
it goes out a pretty enjoyable pace and
knows when to show monsters and when to
let people just be people I'd say there
isn't really bad epic quality that a lot
of the other Sinbad movies have but
there's definitely more personality to
it and I think that makes up for it it's
a swashbuckling tale with a lot of
creativity and some great animation and
no black comedians looking for turbo man
dolls
that's enough for me to say take a look
you